how nasty is the view out of my hotel
room here in sydney australia
i mean there it is right there and there
so pretty pretty lucky
i'm uh i'm one lucky guy and i know it
and i really appreciate you watching
this video and this is a pretty big
video for me
so get ready this is probably going to
be one of the biggest videos
i do in a long long time and it really
talks about
where i'm going the rest of this year so
what i want to talk to you guys about
today is my work work balance
uh obviously work life balance is
something we all work on
and i continue to and this is probably
bleeding from my work-life balance
thoughts because this is a work-life
balance and work work balance
thing for me first of all i want to lose
some weight
yeah it's there guys so that's something
on my mind i want to get a little
healthier my knees
finally healed so i want to start
playing some tennis and basketball
racquetball take that up see what that's
all about probably get crazy competitive
but what i want to talk to you guys
about today and what this video is all
about
is to let the little universe that
actually cares about me
know that i'm making some changes for
2010 i'm making some big changes for
2010
and it's because the reason i got to a
place where i could write a book like
crush and people bought it or the fact
that people want me to come and speak
i'm here in australia to speak at a
conference
which by the way will be one of my last
of 2010 that's the first thing i'm doing
i'm not speaking
uh anymore this year i probably won't
speak at south by southwest next year
i'm probably gonna do a whole year
off the circuit maybe with my book
coming out late this year because i'm
about to write another book that's
another little one i'll be a little
chaotic here
that's how i roll um but i do have a
couple schedule but for example as soon
as i'm done taping this and uploading it
i'll be emailing my good friend ryan
carson telling him i will not speak at
foa
uh though he hasn't formally invited me
um you know usually i do and
he's the best and you should go to pho
london by the way it's an amazing
conference but
i'm going to really really trim down my
speaking circuit
and what else i'm going to do is several
things i'll get
to in a second mainly because i need to
start executing
and i need to start learning again to be
really blunt with you guys i feel like
i've lost a little bit of my edge you
know being really honest with myself for
the last three to four months
i feel like i need to get smarter and
the way i get smarter is by reading
and living putting my head down and
executing i need to taste it one thing i
pride myself
in is the reason i come with such badass
conviction
every time is because i'm not reading it
on somebody else's blog
i'm tasting that stuff that's how i roll
i live it
and then of course i believe it because
i lived it and i saw it happen
i like to execute and right now i feel
like i'm doing something that there's a
great russian saying there's no real
english saying
uh which kind of means
sorry to all the russians that was
butchered um you know i'm putting my one
ass on 10 toilets
and i feel like i'm hitting a lot of
doubles and triples and that's not the
game i want to be playing
and so vaynermedia is very important to
me and i want to come through
dramatically for our clients we just
announced forbes
as a new client and uh campbell's we're
starting to do some work with and
the national hockey league continues to
be a client the jets the nets
mets call me you know so i want to
execute for our clients because hitting
home runs is what going to make
vaynermedia successful
you know i've got other projects that
i'm working on whether it's corked
hip-hop at lunch something i'm starting
to believe in that's been incubated
within
vaynermedia and the fact that cinderella
wine and gourmet library and wine
library
i'm going to start toning down my own
personal brand now
does this mean i'm going to stop
interacting no way still going to be
answering my emails to the best of my
ability but does that mean
for example that i'm going to be
eliminating
see this tweet deck from my computer
yes i am because that little thing
popping up in the corner
distracting because i love the
interaction i love getting
in there with the peeps and i'm going to
continue to do it still have it on my
phone
and i'll still engage my principles
don't change however
everything works when it's in balance
and i need to start learning and
executing i feel
like i need to read some more i just do
i need to read the blogs
i need to i need to read content because
a lot of you have heard that you know
i may not read books and i still may not
but i'm definitely
gonna be in a place where i need to read
two three hours worth of news
i need to get smarter i want to be at
the cutting edge and
and i just need the time i need time to
play basketball
i feel like i need to cut out all this
mentoring and and and these 30-minute
skype interviews and these one-hour
conference calls and all these talks
that i'm doing
and i don't want people to be upset this
this video is probably more for matt
my assistant anybody because he's gonna
have to send this to people because i'm
really bad at saying no i don't want to
say no
i'm so appreciative that people give a
crap
that i want to i want to answer them i
don't think that i'm anything special or
i'm so cool
that i can't answer people or i don't
have time for small things
this has nothing to do with small things
or big things this has to do with the
fact that if you don't execute
you don't win and i feel like i'm
stretched too thin to execute and i need
to cut certain things out
and i've gotten a four year run of
answering all the emails and
engaging with everything and not having
any filter to what's important what's
not because
everything's important to me any one
person whether they have one follower or
eight million followers is important to
me
but the fact that matters is i'm
building businesses and
that's what i want to do i want to build
businesses and
vaynermedia needs my attention and i
need to go there and start building a
business we have a lot of employees now
and i need to help aj it's too much to
throw on somebody that young
um that raw his skill set is insane but
i've got to help him
i want to do it i want to build corked i
want to build this secret thing that i'm
doing i've got another secret thing
that i want to do i've got a new book
the thank you economy coming i need to
write it and i want to crush it because
crush it
was legit but guess what 50 less
things that i'm going to cut out this
year than i would in last year would
have made that book better and that's
what i need to start doing i need to
stop hitting
triples and i need to stop hitting
ground rule doubles and i have to get
back to hitting home runs
and that's what i need to do for myself
i still want to engage i still want to
see people i'm not going anywhere for
example one of the big things with this
new
crazy structured life i have where i'm
boxing everything out scheduling
everything and having like you know time
slots from five to seven to make phone
calls
but that's it like thinking i need to
innovate i need to go buddha and just
think
i need to taste things i need to know
everything that's going on out there i
need to consume it
play with it and touch it and i need to
get in there and get my hands dirty
because that's what i do
i need to do that but what you know i
already lost my train of thought where i
was segwaying from
but what i know is this i uh i want to
execute and i want to come through oh
what i was going to say in this new
regiment regiment kind of
scheduled world i'm thinking about
starting a new show a one-hour q a show
so i don't have to be disappearing from
the world i want to engage
and all those people that emailed me or
hit me up on twitter or asked for 15
minutes of my time
you know now we can do it in that q a
format with everybody i want to come out
with a scheduled q a show me three times
a week
noon to 1 p.m just you know i'll be
there maybe we can build a big community
enjoy that i don't know
i'm brainstorming but here's what i know
i need to change things up
i need a brian matsu's change up because
the fact of the matter is
i want to win and it's all i ever want
to do and i want to come through for my
clients and i want to come through for
my family
and i want to come through and what i do
as a career
and right now i feel like i'm just in
too many places and trying to do too
much i'm only one person
and so i want to get focused and fierce
on it i'm hungry
i'm very hungry and i want to be better
i want to be better for all the people
that are asking me for their
mentorship and for their thoughts and to
help them with their business models
i want to be better for you guys and so
the only way i can do that is to get my
head down
and do what got me here kind of thing
you know this isn't like
oh crap everything's broken this is not
like midlife crisis this is not like
which was
what happened with wine library tv when
i turned 30. this is much more
i need the shape and up this is like the
love handles you know
i need to get lean i'm going to get lean
mentally i'm gonna get
lean business-wise i'm gonna get lean
physically i'm gonna do this
and i don't think i'm really
disappearing in any way this is not my
retirement from being social
in some ways i may be even more social
than i've been over the last three
months because
i'm really trying to figure out the real
grind i want to be good
i want to be legit i want to know what
the hell is going on in
every angle i want to know everything
that's going on with ipad
you know apps i want to know everything
that's going on within the facebook
world because there's so many nuances i
mean
weight to facebook credits blows up and
changes the game
there's just so much going on and i
don't have enough time to get zen
and think about it and devour it the way
i process
is i play with it i touch it i feel it i
use it
and i just need to get better and
smarter and the way i need to do that is
by putting my head down
so this video is made more than anything
else
to really show the people that are going
to keep hitting me up for
hey i'd love to buy you dinner you know
and it's a brilliant move and i love it
and just 15 minutes of your time or
coming to the store
i mean i keep doing this i've done just
way too much yeah come to store for an
hour and it's great and i love it i want
to give back
more than ever more than anything more
than
i breathe that's why i do it but
for me to give back quality i need these
next
nine months for sure for sure for me to
give that quality
i need these next nine months and that's
what i'm gonna do i'm putting my head
down
i'm gonna continue to answer my email to
the best of my ability
um i'm gonna continue to engage and i'll
be around on twitter and facebook and
i'll do all that i'm not going anywhere
as a matter of fact this q a thing i
think could be amazing
but what i'm here to say today is that
um uh i'm working on my work work
balance my balance of
my brand too many business i'm addicted
to biz dev
it's like i'm just addicted to the biz
dev and the opportunities and the
networking
so i'm cutting out the biz dev and the
networking and i just have to
i have to focus on the cake that's in
front of me i'm trying to get too many
pieces of pie
just eat the damn lemon pie gary eat the
damn lemon pie
the apple pie will be there and as a
matter of fact if i do this
over the next nine months i'm gonna be
quicker to grab that apple pie
sorry it's my apple pie so that's what
i'm doing
i i need to focus on what's in front of
me especially vaynermedia it's got my
name on it
with my brother one of the highlights of
my life is the fact that i got to
build a business with my dad
um but i'm not getting that with aj
we're working together
you know and not with each other and i
want that with each other i need to
impose my dna on the vaynermedia team i
want that
i want to know them the way i know my
wine library people and i've just
stretched too many places too many
interviews
too many podcasts saying yes to
everything because i hate saying no
because you know what i don't want to be
like i sold out or i'm not available
this is the right thing for me because
i'm not as smart as i was three years
ago
i'm smarter in a lot of ways but i need
this i need
i need to devour content read put my
head down
yoda it up touch and live stuff and i
need this
and i'm focused and i'm i'm ready i'm
ready
i'm very ready and i want to thank
everybody and i and i apologize
for the people that want to pitch me you
know angel nesting got to focus on what
i've got venmo
you know and and tumblr and
i'm just gonna focus on what i've got
the daily booth i've gotta focus
on what i've got and you know simple geo
i need to come through for those guys i
need to come through for the people that
i've signed up for and invested in
and that's not only my angel investments
but it's
my clients for sure i want to make crazy
[ __ ] happen for the jets and the nets
and forbes magazine and i need to uh i
need to
do this i need to do less about it's
less about my brand
enough with me i feel like i need to go
away for a little bit
you know i'll still be here i will trust
me this is not going to be like i'm off
the grid i'm not off the grid
but but it's going to be more controlled
interaction
that's what it's going to be and i'm
excited about it it's a very
pivotal moment i can't wait to look back
at this video in four years hey gary
man you got a little old um because this
is a another turning point this is
almost five years since i started wine
library tv i had the epiphany
at 30. i feel like i'm 34 and a half i'm
a little ahead of schedule 34 and a
third
um i'm ahead of schedule this time
around i uh
i need to focus i want to write the best
book that's in me for the thank you
economy
i've got two or three projects you don't
even know about that i'm going to focus
on
and i want to pump out good shows for
wine library tv
and i want to get deeper into the wine
business with
a maneuver i'm doing with quark and i
want to know what's going on
i want to read i want i want to go to
hacker news and
and read the titles and not just read
the titles and be like
i want to read i want to be smart and i
need this
for myself for my team for my family and
most of all ironically i need this for
what i've been doing for the last 24
months
i i i want to be awesome when people ask
me questions
i just flew and answered a crapload of
emails and
they were great answers but i want to be
cutting edge i want
i want people to bleed when they
interact with me i'm so cutting edge
and oh i feel like that could be a wrap
anyway and that's it
and that's where i'm going so if you're
watching this video i apologize
that i can't do you know i can't come to
your school and speak which
breaks my heart because i want to or i'm
sorry i'm turning down
that awesome 20 to 40 000
you're offering me to speak but i need
to do this and i'm sorry if i can't just
take five minutes i know it seems so
small
but it's not when you do it 18 000 times
a day
and i'm sorry that i can't do a quick
tea or a coffee
and i'm sorry you know that i can't do a
15 minute podcast so only take 12
minutes or
you want to buy me dinner and i'm sorry
to all the potential awesome angel
investments and biz dev deals that i
would have made
but i need to put my head down i need to
grow that playoff beard i flirted about
earlier this year
and i need to come through for koalas of
the world that i've invested in
to the clients and i know i'm repeating
myself
as you can see i'm instilling it in me
this is how i go i've been flirting for
three months
again you hardcore maniacs you saw the
playoff beer mentions
it's been you know kind of smoking the
fire's here
the fire's in me i'm fired up in a big
way
i feel like i just fired myself um
and i thank everybody for their support
in this please don't think i'm a jerk
off
please and don't mistake this in
any way for the fact that i'm not going
to engage because i am
and the fact that i'm not going to be
around because i am as a matter of fact
i think you know a lot of you
have loved the interaction on ustream
which i love i'm trying to bring that
back that's one of the elements
and uh i just love everybody i wish
everybody the best
and i just want to come out of this at
the end this year i want to come into
2011
as the best as the person that really
knows this better than anybody
whatever this is thank you